President Trump continues to defend his
oldest son for meeting with a Russian
lawyer last year saying most politicians
would have attended Trump jr. says the
meeting was primarily about the
Magnitsky Act the legislation imposes
economic sanctions and travel
restrictions on Russia's name Russians
named as human rights abusers the act is
named after Russian tax attorney Sergei
Magnitsky he died in 2009 in a Russian
prison where he was held for his work
exposing corruption among people linked
to the Kremlin the Russian government
says the cause of death was heart
failure but many observers believe
Magnitsky was murdered
among them is American businessman Bill
Browder who was once the biggest foreign
investor in Russia he has since become a
vocal critic of the country and has
clashed with President Vladimir Putin's
government Magnitsky was router's tax
attorney and Browder was a driving force
behind the legislation and bill is
joining us live in studio great to have
you here bill let's talk about the
Magnitsky Act because in your opinion
you say it is Putin's number one
priority to lift these sanctions from
the Magnitsky Act it affects some 44
Russians right now why is this such a
big deal for Vladimir Putin
well Vladimir Putin is a kleptocrat he's
for 17 years he's been taking lots of
money from the from Russia
he's probably richest man in the world
now and we've been able to trace from
the crime that Sergei Magnitsky exposed
a 230 million dollar tax rebate fraud
and we've been able to trace some of
that money from the fraud to a man named
sergei roldugin who was exposed in the
Panama papers as Putin's trustee or
nominee this is the famous 2 billion
dollar cellist and so Putin has gotten
some of the money and because Putin has
gotten some of the money that means that
all of Putin's money in the West is
potentially exposed and could be frozen
and so this is just a very we know
personal thing for Vladimir Putin that
he doesn't want his money frozen your
book red notice which was written I
think in 2015 right I mean I read it a
couple years ago it's fascinating to go
back and read that given what's
happening now the lawyer and the
lobbyist who met with Don Trump jr. as
well as Paul Manafort and Jared Kushner
what do you think they were up to
well the lawyer her name is Natalia
vessel myths kaya she works for a
Russian oligarch a guy named Peter Katz
Eve Peter cats Eve is a government
official he works for a Russian state
railway company which is one of the most
important companies and he was funding
the anti-magnetic II campaign in America
he was basically I should also point out
that his son's assets were frozen by the
Department of Justice in America because
they also received some of the money
from the Magnitsky crime and so the
natalia vessel minsk i was taking money
from from a Russian oligarch who's close
to Vladimir Putin to try to overturn the
Magnitsky Act
she then hires this guy Rinat Akhmetov
who is a by all accounts some kind of
shady
so former Soviet spy current spy
operator in Washington and he then
organizes a full-on lobbying campaign
hiring the top lobbyists the top law
firms the top PR firms to try to get me
to this moment her family says but
nothing came of this meeting it was a
nothing burger well so so let's just
look at it very simply Vladimir Putin
wants to get rid of this this act that's
gonna sanction his assets it's his top
priority
he sends he assigns and oligarchs to go
in and spend all the money to get rid of
it and the Russians the Russian KGB is
not stupid they want something in return
and we don't know we don't know what
happened in that meeting we don't know
who said what to whom because he can't
trust the Russians and and the Trump
people keep keep on changing their story
so who knows what kind of burger it is
so here's what we do know you called her
quote probably the most aggressive
person I have ever encountered in all of
my conflicts in all of my contacts with
Russians that's correct most aggressive
person I've ever encountered yeah so so
I mean that this this person is she's
remarkable she had an unlimited budget
and I should I should caveat that she's
not aggressive in a physical in a
physical way okay this is all done
legally lobbying wise investigation wise
they were trapped they they had they
were surveilling me around the country
they were they were spending money on
every different legal motion they could
come up with they were hiring lobbyists
left right and center they were getting
to Donald Trump jr.
all on behalf of Vladimir Putin to get
rid of the Magnitsky Act you believe
there is a collusion to impact
the American election which is a
different question I have no idea all I
can say is I know the Russian side
intimately and I can tell you that this
was a highly resourced operation to get
rid of a piece of legislation that would
affect Vladimir Putin personally and I
emailed you directly right after a word
of the New York Times in the meeting
when the mention of adoption and orphans
came to mind when Donald Trump jr. said
that's what she wanted to talk about it
goes far beyond just adoption because
explain to our viewers that was lad Amir
Putin's retaliation right to the
Magnitsky Act and not allowing Americans
to adopt Russian babies any more Russian
children so if Vladimir Putin was so
angry about the Magnitsky Act that he
was looking for some type of retaliation
he couldn't freeze assets or do other
types of things because the Americans
would retaliate against that and so he
came up with the most heartless
vindictive thing he could do which was
Americans were adopting disabled Russian
orphans and he said no you can't adopt
them anymore and there was like five
hundred families who had met babies and
children who were like longing to go
home to America to be and I should say
these were sick orphans the ones with
HIV and Down syndrome because the
Russians weren't letting the the healthy
ones go and so effectively Putin said no
American adoptions these kids weren't
coming to America they're some of them
end up dying in orphanages because they
weren't being treated properly have you
been threatened and do you fear for your
life in any way I have been threatened
on a number of occasions by agents of
the Russian government and by Dmitry
Medvedev himself the former president
and current prime minister of Russia and
I do fear for my life
there's so much more to talk about bill
Thank You Lenny safe yeah thank you for
having me on